[Music]
Olympics on everybody's mind these days
and of course the media is only focusing
on the important issues for example this
was the big story today a member of the
US rowing team who won a bronze medal is
accused of having an erection while on
the medal stand furries everywhere
there's photos yeah the rower is
claiming his penis wasn't erect it was
just standing for the national anthem
[Applause]
that's a patriotic I didn't even know
that was a thing that's gonna put so
much pressure on me at all ballgames
what having to get an erection during
the nationally we're saying I didn't
know an erection was a thing really I
felt sorry for a whole bunch of people
right there what is this thing you're
talking about big story at the Olympics
though regarding Michael Phelps he
stepped out with his girlfriend
yesterday for the first time people got
to see his girlfriend yes very pretty
Michael Phelps girlfriend is a 25 year
old model from Los Angeles in other
words like every other model in LA she's
dating an older retired guy
[Applause]
Wow thank you thanks gang I do like that
yeah it's now come out that just before
his record-breaking 100 meter dash gold
medalist Hussain Bolt ate at McDonalds
yeah apparently he timed his meal so
that when the race started he would have
exactly nine point six three seconds to
get to a toilet
I think that was the tape breaking yeah
oh you know better he was hit by doves
exploded Olympic officials have
disqualified a champion race Walker
after term in the after determining that
he was doping the disqualified him yeah
the men says getting caught doping is
almost as embarrassing is getting caught
being a champion race Walker
that's not here that's not really but
yeah that's Charlie Chaplin what I'm
doing yeah
this what so okay there you go that face
you're making during that what are you
all mad about throwing that's my
aggressive style okay someone the other
race walkers elbows you'd be good tough
Olympic news for the Romneys yep Ann
Romney's horse rafalca did not advance
to the Olympic finals yeah he apparently
was beat out by a smooth-talking
socialist horse from Kenya
you know for my money biggest American
hero these days is that Mars rover
there's nothing incredible just so
exciting well today scientists at NASA
released the Mars rovers first video yes
sadly it's the Rovers audition tape for
American Idol here's my number call me
maybe no that's just sad you were
correct give yourself some credit
hey Mayor Bloomberg is saying that now
that he has banned large sodas in New
York City his next target is going to be
alcohol yeah
and once that's out of the way he'll
start his crusade against the laughter
of children
[Applause]
I thought that d'azyr singing a new
study just came out it says you can tell
if a man is gay by how much his pupils
dilate when he sees an image of a naked
man yeah
also by whether or not he shouts me
likey
I should just be the whole test right
there